Alice:哎呀天呐误撞打误进来来发现切皮蛋的妙招那就是把他冷冻起来
Alice:啧好的不是妙我招切不动
Alice: Well, it's not exactly a trick, I still can't cut it.
Alice:冻的比我的命都硬但是他不会乱流了
Alice: It's frozen harder than my life, but at least it doesn't ooze everywhere.
Katrina: 我现在看你们干所有事情都觉得很神奇那我妈也不会做这种从来没有见过的
Katrina: Everything you guys do seems amazing to me. My mom has never done anything like this.
Tasha: 把他们搅合到完全融合的状态就是你及看不到他像你看他现在就是还有油花在这个里面所以就还没有融合
Tasha: Mix them until they are fully blended. You see, now there are still some oil spots in it, so it's not fully mixed yet.
Alice:带了鲁
Alice: It's got brine.
Lucia: 额呵呵
Lucia: Eh hehe
Tasha: 可以了
Tasha: It's okay now.
Katrina: 呵呵呵
Katrina: Hehehe
Tasha: 40克好像我记错了
Tasha: 40 grams, I think I remembered it wrong.
Tasha: 40克
Tasha: 40 grams.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Katrina: 我可以划过你
Katrina: Can I pass you?
Tasha: 你可以转一转吗
Tasha: Can you turn a bit?
Lucia: 在哪啊
Lucia: Where is it?
Tasha: 搅拌到看不出一点粉来
Tasha: Stir until you can't see any powder.
Katrina: 看不出一点粉来
Katrina: Until you can't see any powder.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Lucia: 你怎么知道
Lucia: How do you know?
Tasha: 哦对
Tasha: Oh, right.
Tasha: 好像币啊好像是
Tasha: It looks like coins, I think.
Alice: 我要开始了
Alice: I'm about to start.
Tasha: 好的
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina:  热水烧好了耶
Katrina: The hot water is ready.
Tasha: 你要来抽蛋黄吗
Tasha: Do you want to take out the egg yolk?
Katrina:  嗯我要
Katrina: Yes, I do.
Alice: 哎我们家的油呢
Alice: Hey, where's our oil?
Lucia: 呃玉米油行吗
Lucia: Uh, will corn oil work?
Alice:随便
Alice: Whatever.
Tasha: 玉米油
Tasha: Corn oil.
Katrina:  这是后来加了什么
Katrina: What did we add later?
Alice:随便是油就行
Alice: Any oil will do.
Alice: 呃给我一点点点纸好吗
Alice: Uh, can you give me a bit of paper?
Lucia:啊是面粉吧
Lucia: Ah, it's flour, right?
Lucia: 我们加的
Lucia: We added it.
Lucia: 牛奶加
Lucia: Added milk.
Alice:耶耶耶
Alice: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tasha: OK可以了
Tasha: OK, it's done.
Tasha: 我看一下
Tasha: Let me take a look.
Tasha: 嗯可以了
Tasha: Hmm, it's fine.
Tasha: 到你了呵呵呵呵
Tasha: It's your turn, hahaha.
Alice: 我们的葱姜蒜呢
Alice: Where's our green onion, ginger, and garlic?
Tasha: 葱姜蒜
Tasha: Green onion, ginger, and garlic.
Alice: 这里边
Alice: It's in here.
Lucia: 在调料那一袋里面似乎
Lucia: Seems to be in the seasoning bag.
小薇 就在调料里面
Tasha: It's in the seasoning.
Katrina: 一个方向打就行
Katrina: Just mix in one direction.
Alice:ok
Alice: OK.
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Alice: where where
Alice: Where, where?
Alice: 我尊嘟很急
Alice: I'm really in a hurry.
Alice:嗯没有啊啊有哇有好累呀
Alice: Hmm, no... ah, there it is, phew, so tiring.
Alice: 我们那个现成的蒜呢
Alice: Where's our pre-peeled garlic?
Lucia: 现成的蒜应该是
Lucia: The pre-peeled garlic should be...
Alice: 现成的蒜
Alice: Pre-peeled garlic.
Alice: 是不是在那里边
Alice: Is it in there?
Tasha: 现成的蒜
Tasha: Pre-peeled garlic.
Tasha: 看一眼
Tasha: Let me check.
Tasha: 蒜蒜在这呀
Tasha: The garlic, it's here.
Alice:蒜
Alice: Garlic.
Alice: 不是蒜苗蒜就那个白白胖胖的
Alice: Not the garlic sprouts, just the white, plump one.
Alice: 嗯左左左左左上角
Alice: Hmm, left, left, left, upper left corner.
Alice: 那那那给我一点就行了
Alice: That one, just give me a bit.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Alice: 拿出来就行
Alice: Just take it out.
Lucia: 给
Lucia: Here.
Lucia: 行好
Lucia: Alright.
Tasha: 啊对
Tasha: Ah, right.
Tasha: good哈哈哈
Tasha: Good, hahaha.
Tasha: OK然后差不多有时间的话
Tasha: OK, if we have time.
Tasha: 我们可以把楼上的那个打蛋盆拿下来
Tasha: We can bring down the egg beater bowl from upstairs.
Lucia: 啊看一眼
Lucia: Ah, let me check.
Lucia: 现在没关系
Lucia: It's fine now.
Lucia: 好像还差几分钟
Lucia: Seems like a few more minutes.
Lucia: 三分钟
Lucia: Three minutes.
Tasha: 三分钟嗯
Tasha: Three minutes, yeah.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Tasha: 拿下来吧
Tasha: Take it down.
Lucia: 可以啦 OK可以了没关系
Lucia: It's fine, okay, it's fine.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Alice: 没有围裙对吧
Alice: No aprons, right?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Alice:好就这样吧
Alice: Alright, just leave it like that.
Alice:算了自己剥吧
Alice: Forget it, peel it yourself.
Tasha:接下来把蛋清
Tasha: Next, separate the egg whites.
Tasha: 就是刚刚蛋黄和蛋清要分开
Tasha: Just separate the yolks and whites.
Tasha: 分开之后他们现在先把蛋清打发一下这个不用
Tasha: After separating, whip the egg whites a bit, no need for this.
Alice:谁可以帮我剥点蒜
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Hey.
Alice: 有人 有手吗
Alice: Anyone, got a hand?
Tasha: 剥个蒜
Tasha: Peel some garlic.
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Katrina:  我帮你剥
Katrina: I'll help you peel.
Alice: 那个是密密封的
Alice: That one is sealed tightly.
Alice: 我想等到你们那个火锅的时候再用
Alice: I want to use it when you guys do the hot pot.
Katrina:  我帮你吧
Katrina: I'll help you.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Tasha: 好那你别做了呵呵
Tasha: Alright, then don't do it, haha.
Alice:啊这点就行
Alice: Ah, that's enough.
Alice:有点小不太好剥应该
Alice: It's a bit small, hard to peel.
Lucia: 来喽
Lucia: Here it comes.
Tasha: 要放在这
Tasha: Put it here.
Alice:嗯算了不弄皮了就这样吧反正洗锅
Alice: Hmm, forget it, don't peel it, just like this is fine, wash the pot.
Katrina: 天呐哎呀ai在我这采集数据可杂了一会干这一会干呢
Katrina: Oh my, AI is collecting data from me, one moment doing this, one moment doing that.
Tasha: 能把白砂糖拿来吗
Tasha: Can you bring the white sugar?
Lucia: 白砂糖在哪
Lucia: Where's the white sugar?
Alice:在这
Alice: It's here.
Alice:这个这个这个这个里面吧应该
Alice: It's in this, this, this, this, here.
Lucia: 哎这个白糖他可以撕开之后还能用
Lucia: Hey, can you still use this white sugar after you tear it open?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia: 那种拉面的是吗
Lucia: The kind for ramen, right?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 哎呦
Tasha: Oh, wow.
Alice:好的假装没看到
Alice: Alright, pretend you didn't see that.
Lucia: 呵呵
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 放35克
Tasha: Add 35 grams.
Alice:哎呦我的妈呀
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Alice:嗯没事我剥点
Alice: Hmm, it's okay, I'll peel some.
Alice:这蒜太小了不好剥
Alice: This garlic is too small, it's hard to peel.
Alice: 有底下呢
Alice: There's some at the bottom.
Lucia: 嗯你看一眼
Lucia: Hmm, take a look.
Lucia: 这样可以吗
Lucia: Is this okay?
Tasha:他倒了35克就行
Tasha: He just needs to pour 35 grams.
Lucia: 倒了35.2吗
Lucia: Did he pour 35.2 grams?
Tasha: 蒜蒜在这呀
Tasha: The garlic is over here.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's fine.
Katrina: 挑好了
Katrina: I picked it.
Tasha: 任何东西都不能沾水
Tasha: Nothing should touch water.
Alice:难剥
Alice: Hard to peel.
Alice:哦待会用
Alice: Oh, we'll use it later.
Alice:;哎
Alice: Ugh.
Lucia: 我吧这个白盆放到哎这上面好像已经放满了
Lucia: I'll put this white bowl... Oh, it's already full here.
Lucia: 管他呢随他挤一点位置
Lucia: Whatever, just squeeze it in.
Tasha: 你看他现在是蛋清的样子对吧
Tasha: You see, now it looks like egg whites, right?
Tasha: 这是35克
Tasha: This is 35 grams.
Alice:哎这蒜真不好
Alice: Ugh, this garlic is really bad.
Tasha: 第一遍只要打出这种细
Tasha: For the first round, just beat it until it's fine like this.
Alice: 你们是不是明天用火锅
Alice: Are you guys having hotpot tomorrow?
Katrina: 应该是明天晚上吧
Katrina: Probably tomorrow night.
Alice: 受不了了我要用那个蒜了
Alice: I can't stand it, I need to use that garlic.
Katrina:  要等他回来才
Katrina: We have to wait for him to come back.
Tasha: 呃再帮我取5克玉米淀粉吧
Tasha: Uh, can you get me 5 grams of cornstarch?
Alice:呀
Alice: Ah.
Lucia: 呃15克
Lucia: Uh, 15 grams.
Tasha: 5克呃
Tasha: 5 grams, uh.
Lucia: 5克
Lucia: 5 grams.
Tasha: 用这个用这个取
Tasha: Use this, use this to get it.
Lucia: 这个就先拿下来
Lucia: Let's take this down first.
Lucia: 啊啊
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Katrina: 还要加柠檬啊
Katrina: Do we need to add lemon?
Tasha: 加过了
Tasha: Already added.
Lucia: 为什么要加柠檬
Lucia: Why add lemon?
Tasha: 去腥
Tasha: To remove the smell.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
小薇 嗯对对对5克就行
Tasha: Yeah, yeah, 5 grams is enough.
Tasha: 然后第二遍是这个状态就行
Tasha: Then the second round, it should look like this.
Lucia: 哇嗯
Lucia: Wow, okay.
Tasha: 然后最后一遍
Tasha: And then one last time.
Lucia: 好神奇但就像把他
Lucia: It's amazing, but it's like...
Lucia: 等一下这个要把它再清理一下吗
Lucia: Wait a second, do we need to clean this up again?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Tasha: 5克
Tasha: 5 grams.
Tasha: 可以可以
Tasha: Perfect, perfect.
Alice: 我们有没有汤勺
Alice: Do we have any ladles?
Alice: 应该有吧
Alice: We should have, right?
Alice: 没有汤勺吗
Alice: No ladles?
Tasha: 有
Tasha: We do.
Lucia: 汤勺我好像也没看见
Lucia: I don't think I've seen any ladles either.
Lucia: 看他们这有没有
Lucia: Check if they have any.
Alice:这个是吗
Alice: Is this one?
Alice:就这个吧
Alice: Let's just use this one.
Alice:这一步是要把水锅里的水给
Alice: This step is to evaporate some water from the pot, right?
Alice:蒸发一下不然他会怎么样呢
Alice: Otherwise, what will happen?
Alice: 他会啪啦啪啦的
Alice: It'll start popping.
Alice:就是水跟油互相
Alice: Because water and oil...
Alice:他们不是好朋友他们会打架虽然是玉米油
Alice: They're not friends, they'll fight, even though it's corn oil.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Alice:但是就这样吧
Alice: But let's just do it this way.
Alice:食材多的话就多倒一点点吧
Alice: If there are more ingredients, just add a bit more.
Alice:其实我放错顺序了我应该先放皮蛋的
Alice: Actually, I did it in the wrong order. I should've added the century eggs first.
Alice:热水在吗
Alice: Is the hot water ready?
Alice:哦谢谢
Alice: Oh, thanks.
Alice:;我觉得应该在放点油他就沾锅了
Alice: I think we should add more oil; it's sticking to the pan.
Katrina:  大概能装多少个
Katrina: How many can this hold?
Tasha: 呃这个
Tasha: Uh, this...
Tasha: 哈哈哈 好
Tasha: Hahaha, okay.
Katrina: 装了再说吧
Katrina: Let's fill it up and see.
Tasha: 就就这样放着吧
Tasha: Just leave it like this.
Lucia: 行呃
Lucia: Alright, um...
Tasha: 不太能确定
Tasha: Can't be too sure.
Lucia: 没事装完要是不够
Lucia: It's okay, if it's not enough...
Lucia: 我们再拿出几个杯子
Lucia: We'll get a few more cups.
Tasha: 可以放到这个里面
Tasha: We can put it in this.
Tasha: 因为这个有个嘴
Tasha: Because this has a spout.
Tasha: 他好倒啊
Tasha: It's easier to pour.
Tasha: 所以这个杯子他既可以倒嘴
Tasha: So this cup can be used for pouring.
Tasha: 然后呢他还有容容量
Tasha: And it also has capacity.
Tasha: 大家可以都试试
Tasha: Everyone can try it.
Lucia: 咦你先来啊
Lucia: Hey, you go first.
Katrina:  好你先打样
Katrina: Okay, you set an example.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Tasha: 下一个
Tasha: Next one.
Tasha: 果断的挪没关系
Tasha: Just move decisively, it's okay.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Tasha: 那你倒吧
Tasha: Then you pour it.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh no.
Lucia: 让我按一下这个油烟机
Lucia: Let me press this extractor fan.
Lucia: 又倒了
Lucia: It fell again.
Alice:啧感觉好像坏掉了算了不放他了
Alice: Ugh, it feels like it's broken, forget it, let's not use it.
Katrina: 这大概烤多久
Katrina: How long should we bake this?
Tasha: 额
Tasha: Uh...
Tasha: 正好吃饭吃完饭吧
Tasha: Just finish eating, and we'll eat it after.
Alice:坏掉了这个
Alice: This is broken.
Tasha: 20多分钟
Tasha: About 20 minutes.
Tasha: 对他先低温烤熟然后高温上色
Tasha: Yeah, first bake it at low temperature, then increase the temperature for coloring.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 咦那我就先把这个菜拿出来了
Lucia: Hey, I'll take this dish out first.
Alice:白菜呢
Alice: Where's the cabbage?
Lucia: 哎在这里
Lucia: Ah, here.
Lucia: 我害怕洗那个什么洗到里面就拿出来了
Lucia: I was afraid of washing it into the sink, so I took it out.
Alice:哦我涮一下这个
Alice: Oh, let me rinse this.
Lucia: 嗯咱这应该
Lucia: Hmm, we should have
Lucia: 有抹布
Lucia: a cloth.
Lucia: 是
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 没有的话额
Lucia: If not, uh...
Lucia: 那个那个海绵有点脏有点不想用额那还有一个
Lucia: That sponge is a bit dirty, I don't really want to use it, uh, there's another one.
Jake: 开饭了
Jake: Time to eat!
Tasha: 哦烤上啦
Tasha: Oh, it's baking!
Jake: 呜呜呜呜呜呜
Jake: Woo woo woo woo woo!
Jake: 虽然完全不知道怎么做的
Jake: Even though I have no idea how it was made,
Jake: 但是一定很好吃
Jake: it must be delicious.
Tasha: 谢谢你
Tasha: Thank you.
Tasha: 这个也快好了好像
Tasha: This one is almost done too, I think.
Lucia: 你错过了这个非常精彩的打蛋环节真的很神奇
Lucia: You missed a very exciting egg-beating session, it was amazing!
Jake: 哦怎么个
Jake: Oh, how so?
Jake: 发起来的是吧
Jake: Did it rise?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Lucia: 虽然没打成那种泡沫状的
Lucia: Even though it didn't turn out foamy
Jake: 哦可以没事你们踩到了数据
Jake: Oh, it's okay, you guys hit the data
Tasha: 哈哈哈他晚上回去看数据
Tasha: Hahaha, he'll check the data when he gets back
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈  对呵
Jake: Hahaha, yeah
Jake: 让世界研究员们都看到
Jake: Let the world researchers see
Jake: 这个鸡蛋哎
Jake: This egg, hey
Jake: 怎么打碎了呀
Jake: How did it break
Jake: 打碎的瞬间
Jake: At the moment it broke
Alice: 为什么这个汤变成这个样子了
Alice: Why did this soup turn out like this
Alice: 好暗啊
Alice: So dark
Tasha: 这是被我们惩罚的鸡蛋
Tasha: This is the egg we punished
Alice:感觉要翻车了
Alice: Feels like it's going to fail
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah
Alice: 不太妙的预感
Alice: I have a bad feeling
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Alice:我有不太妙的预感
Alice: I have a bad feeling
Jake:有点厉害
Jake: A little impressive
Alice:感觉要翻车了
Alice: Feels like it's going to fail
Alice: 感觉要翻车了
Lucia: 这个是是
Lucia: This is
Alice:你洗的叶子
Alice: The leaves you washed
Jake: 好我看一下
Jake: Okay, let me take a look
Jake: 我来研究研究
Jake: I'll study it
Jake: 它感觉要转出来了离奇
Jake: It feels like it's going to turn out strangely
Lucia: 我刚才拿了一下我看他底下好像没有网一样的感觉我就我就不敢不敢一直把他拿起来了
Lucia: I just picked it up and it felt like there was no net underneath, so I didn't dare to keep lifting it up
Alice: 嗯大白菜还是太冒险了
Alice: Hmm, napa cabbage is still too risky
Jake: 我也我也
Jake: Me too, me too
Jake: 整不明白
Jake: I don't get it
Lucia: 是吧
Lucia: Right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah
Lucia: 感觉他底下没有网
Lucia: Feels like there's no net underneath
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah
Jake: 那这哎
Jake: So this, hey
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
Alice:哎呀怎么老翻锅呀
Alice: Oh no, why does it keep overturning
Jake: 那这个怎么办呀呵呵
Jake: So what do we do with this, haha
Jake: 这也只能打开吧
Jake: We can only open it
Lucia: 对他如果透出好像下不去哦有网sorry
Lucia: Yeah, if he exposes it, it seems like it won't work. Sorry.
Lucia: 是一种试错觉的效果
Lucia: It's kind of like an illusion effect.
Jake: 行没问题
Jake: Alright, no problem.
Alice: 我不知道为什么
Alice: I don't know why.
Alice: 这个颜色变成这个样子了
Alice: The color turned out like this.
Alice: 感觉要翻车了
Alice: Feels like it's going to fail.
Alice: 怎么办好害怕
Alice: What should we do? I'm so scared.
Jake: 别怕别怕
Jake: Don't worry, don't worry.
Jake: 好吃
Jake: It's delicious.
Alice: 好吃吗
Alice: Is it delicious?
Jake: 好吃，对一定好吃
Jake: Yes, it's definitely delicious.
Alice: 我我我已经开始害怕了
Alice: I, I, I'm already starting to get scared.
Alice: 有一种不太妙的预感
Alice: I have a bad feeling about this.
Tasha: 充电宝
Tasha: Power bank.
Tasha: 充电宝有充电的吗
Tasha: Is there a power bank charging?
Jake: 应该有吧
Jake: There should be.
Lucia: 啊啊sorry
Lucia: Ah, sorry.
Alice:没事没事
Alice: It's okay, it's okay.
Alice: 白菜帮不要
Alice: Don't want the cabbage core.
Lucia: 那个碗上那去了
Lucia: Where did that bowl go?
Tasha: 是烧菜的吗
Tasha: Is it for cooking?
Alice: 啊可能是
Alice: Ah, maybe.
Lucia: 呃没事再重拉一个吧
Lucia: Uh, it's okay, let's just redo it.
Jake: 对再拉
Jake: Yeah, redo it.
Jake: 刚刚我头在下面一直一刀下去
Jake: Just now, my head was down and it felt like a cut.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Jake: 有一种哎呀Lucia你好像你好像
Jake: It felt like, oh Lucia, you seemed like, you seemed like...
Lucia: 需要一个碗
Lucia: Need a bowl.
Jake: 这个灯不亮了
Jake: This light isn't on.
Jake: 可能是满了
Jake: Maybe it's full.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake: 你要不看一下
Jake: Do you want to check it?
Lucia: 稍等
Lucia: Hold on.
Jake: 哈哈哈就感觉断头的感觉
Jake: Haha, felt like getting beheaded.
Lucia: 但是我的薇片没有掉线啊
Lucia: But my Wi-Fi didn't disconnect.
Lucia: 嗯可是他冲了很长时间的电
Lucia: Hmm, but it charged for a long time.
Lucia: 我猜他应该是有变的
Lucia: I guess it should have charged.
Lucia: 不会没电了吧
Lucia: It can't be out of power, right?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 再看一下
Jake: Check again.
Alice: 盐在哪里
Alice: Where's the salt?
Lucia: 他现在还没连上了吗
Lucia: Has he not connected yet?
Lucia: 他这里有有一段不过可能中间他他断了
Lucia: There's a segment here, but it might have disconnected in the middle.
Lucia: 应该没电断了那那现在要继续把他吸
Lucia: Probably ran out of battery. We need to keep charging it.
Jake: 就要插着电了
Jake: It needs to be plugged in.
Jake: 刚好现在有兜了
Jake: Now there's a pocket.
Lucia: 对对对我刚好现在有兜了
Lucia: Yes, yes, I have a pocket now.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 那我要怎么把他重新命名一下吗
Lucia: Do I need to rename it?
Jake: 没关系
Jake: It's fine.
Jake: 这样的话其实是别人没电就你还有电还能行
Jake: This way, when others run out of battery, you still have power.
Jake: 因为大家可能很快
Jake: Because everyone might quickly...
Jake: 不是没有点是没有sorry
Jake: Not without points, but without battery, sorry.
Jake: 就你还有很多sorry
Jake: You still have a lot, sorry.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:呀
Alice: Ah.
Alice:熟了
Alice: It's done.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 没有我再看一眼你再发那个
Lucia: No, let me take another look before you send it.
Tasha: 我我什么都没发在瞎画
Tasha: I didn't send anything, just doodling.
Lucia: 啊没有没有我是说你在设计一个表情包
Lucia: Oh no, I meant you were designing an emoji.
Lucia: 哈哈跨服聊天
Lucia: Haha, cross-server chat.
Alice:或许需要一点水
Alice: Maybe it needs a bit of water.
Alice:;累死我了
Alice: I'm exhausted.
Alice: 翻车翻车
Alice: It's a mess, a mess.
Alice: 这个颜色不太对
Alice: This color isn't right.
Alice: 应该是奶白色的
Alice: It should be milky white.
Alice: 不知道为什么
Alice: I don't know why.
Lucia: 没事我觉得应该会很好吃对你影响了什么
Lucia: It's okay, I think it will taste good. Did it affect anything?
Lucia: 哎绝了
Lucia: Oh, amazing.
Alice: 我很难受
Alice: I feel terrible.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thank you.
Lucia: 额你是放哪个薇波炉里吗
Lucia: Oh, which microwave did you use?
Katrina:  咋了
Katrina: What happened?
Lucia: 没有就是我们的外卖到了
Lucia: Nothing, our delivery arrived.
Jake: 哦强势保温
Jake: Oh, strong heat retention.
Lucia:哈哈 所以经常就放在薇波炉里保温了
Lucia: Haha, so we often keep it warm in the microwave.
Lucia: 物尽其用啊真
Lucia: Making the most of it.
Lucia: 能放下吗
Lucia: Can it fit?
Jake: 但是问题不大
Jake: But it's not a big deal.
Jake: 楼上我们还有一个
Jake: We have one more upstairs.
Lucia: 哦有道理
Lucia: Oh, makes sense.
Lucia: 可能是剑拔弩张哈哈
Lucia: It might be a tense situation, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:有没有人先来尝一下毒
Alice: Is anyone going to try the poison first?
Alice: 但是这个颜色不知道为什么
Alice: But this color, I don't know why...
Alice: 你能不能把它想象成奶白色
Alice: Can you imagine it being milky white?
Katrina:  可以啊
Alice: 不知道为什么他好黑
Alice: I don't know why it's so dark.
Alice: 我好难受
Alice: I feel so uncomfortable.
Tasha:陆宇
Tasha: Luyu.
Lucia: 因为皮蛋原因吧
Lucia: It's probably because of the century egg.
Alice: 不是就是之前是白的不知道为什么这次是乌漆嘛黑的
Alice: No, it used to be white. I don't know why it's so pitch black this time.
Alice:可能没放牛奶或者怎样给你少盛一点吧害怕你受不了
Alice: Maybe we didn't add milk or something. I'll give you a little less because I'm afraid you can't handle it.
Alice:啧哎这个颜色好害怕呀家人
Alice: Ugh, this color is so scary, guys.
Lucia: 哈哈没事好吃就行
Lucia: Haha, it's fine as long as it tastes good.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice:我真的很害怕
Alice: I'm really scared.
Lucia: 而且
Lucia: And...
Lucia: 有勺吗
Lucia: Is there a spoon?
Alice:啊这个颜色好死亡啊
Alice: Ah, this color looks like death.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 他这应该有一个
Lucia: There should be one here.
Alice:有筷子
Alice: There are chopsticks.
Alice:但是他筷子很多
Alice: But there are a lot of chopsticks.
Alice:用筷子吧
Alice: Let's use chopsticks.
Tasha: 那就上次那谁用的一次性筷子
Tasha: Then we can use those disposable chopsticks that someone used last time.
Lucia: 今天中午剩下的那些一次性筷子不知道够不够可能在楼上一会上去看一看
Lucia: The leftover disposable chopsticks from lunch today might not be enough. Maybe we should go upstairs and check.
Lucia: 楼上有筷子
Lucia: There are chopsticks upstairs.
Katrina: 他也有
Katrina: He has some too.
Alice:不知道为什么
Alice: I don't know why...
Lucia: 也有那些锅碗瓢盆的
Lucia: There are also those pots and pans.
Alice:哎呦撕再摔几次他不就死掉了
Alice: Oh, if we drop it a few more times, it might just break.
Alice: 和他换个位置吧
Alice: Let's switch places with him.
Tasha: 一个结构的
Tasha: The same structure.
Alice:呵呵你要喝吗这个颜色有点死亡你饿了吗
Alice: Haha, do you want to drink it? This color looks a bit deadly. Are you hungry?
Tasha: 呃没有好喝吗
Tasha: Uh, no. Does it taste good?
Alice:你要来点吗
Alice: Do you want some?
Alice: 这个颜色
Alice: This color...
Tasha: 我先尝尝
Tasha: Let me try it first.
Alice: 你能不能把它想象成奶白色
Alice: Can you imagine it being milky white?
Tasha: 啊怎么会变成这个颜色
Tasha: Huh, how did it turn this color?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Alice:不知道
Alice: No idea.
Tasha: 我想先尝尝咸淡
Tasha: I want to taste it first for saltiness.
Alice: 你拿直接勺吧
Alice: Just use the spoon directly.
Alice: 也没有别的
Tasha: 嗯我觉得可以
Tasha: Hmm, I think it's okay.
Alice: 咸吗
Alice: Is it salty?
Tasha: 我觉得可以再加一点点盐
Tasha: I think we can add a little more salt.
Alice: 再加点盐
Alice: Add more salt.
Katrina:  有点咸是吗
Katrina: Is it a bit salty?
Tasha: 嗯那可能我喝的有点少吧
Tasha: Hmm, maybe I didn't drink enough.
Alice: 有点咸还有点甜
Alice: It's a bit salty and a bit sweet.
Katrina:  咸，不是我吃正好不用加盐了我的意思是
Katrina: Salty, I mean I don't need to add salt, it's just right for me.
Alice: 你要加盐吗
Alice: Do you want to add salt?
Tasha: 呃我不加了
Tasha: Uh, I won't add any.
Tasha: 呃给我也来一碗
Tasha: Uh, get me a bowl too.
Alice: 你自己来点吧
Alice: Serve yourself a bit.
Tasha: 呃不了不了你帮我加一碗就行了
Tasha: Uh, no, no, you help me add a bowl.
Tasha: 为什么大家不吃饭
Tasha: Why isn't anyone eating?
Alice: 还没到吧
Alice: It's not time yet.
Tasha: 哎刚刚饭不是到了吗
Tasha: Hey, didn't the food just arrive?
Katrina:  哈哈开玩笑的
Katrina: Haha, just kidding.
Alice: 给 你饿了吗
Alice: Here, are you hungry?
Tasha: 多吗嗯你倒入一点
Tasha: Is it a lot? Hmm, you pour a bit.
Tasha: 大家一人有一碗吗
Tasha: Does everyone have a bowl?
Alice: 足足的
Alice: Plenty.
Tasha: 好 我问一下   饭呢
Tasha: Okay, let me ask. Where's the rice?
Alice:可爱
Alice: Cute.
Alice:哎
Alice: Hey.
Alice: 失误了  我的错
Alice: Mistake, my bad.
Alice:什么东西
Alice: What's that?
Alice:没放胡椒粉
Alice: Didn't add pepper.
Tasha: 学的啥呀
Tasha: What did you learn?
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Haha.
Katrina: 这还要放胡椒粉
Katrina: Does it need pepper?
Alice:嗯会有加一点点味道
Alice: Yeah, adding a little will enhance the flavor.
Jake: 斗舞是吧
Jake: Dance battle, huh?
Alice:现在
Alice: Now.
Tasha: 好了大家都下来吃饭了
Tasha: Okay, everyone come down to eat.
Tasha: 不过为什么不在上面吃呢
Tasha: But why aren't we eating upstairs?
Lucia: 有道理下面好像比上面乱一点
Lucia: Makes sense, it's a bit messier down here than upstairs.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Lucia: 我想把这个拿上去
Lucia: I want to take this upstairs.
Jake:好
Jake: Sure.
Tasha: 好你要不要把那个锅拿上去
Tasha: Do you want to take that pot upstairs?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Tasha: 把这碗汤汤端上去
Tasha: Take this bowl of soup upstairs.
Alice: 端上去
Alice: Take it upstairs.
Tasha: 对因为不是在上面吃饭吗
Tasha: Yeah, since we’re eating upstairs, right?
Alice:哦不知道
Alice: Oh, I didn't know.
Jake: 好我先端上去
Jake: Okay, I'll take it up first.
Lucia: 这个袋子里面好像也有汤的呀子
Lucia: It seems like there's soup in this bag too.
Tasha: 水煮肉片吧
Tasha: It's probably boiled pork slices.
Lucia: 哎我刚刚我这个外卖里也有水煮肉
Lucia: Oh, my takeout also had boiled pork slices.
Lucia: 那个
Lucia: That...
Alice:哎把他想象成奶白色的话会不会好点 受不了了就是乌漆嘛黑的很难过
Alice: Hey, would it be better if we imagine it as milky white? I can't stand it being all dark and gloomy.